jamais rien vécu et jamais rien fait de
sa vie
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans sa
cuisine et bain je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'ils
avaient une équipe de 25 usines et
autour pour nous pour nos fournisseurs
pour nos équipes c'était essentiel
d'ouvrir le plus tôt possible
beaucoup disent que la vie ne reprendra
pas de la même façon je n'adhère pas à
cette théorie du monde d'avant du monde
d'après je crois que le groupe d'avants
il était formidable et qu'on a envie de
le retrouver pensé que ça allait me
rendre plus tolérante et ça m'a rendu
plus adhérente
alors parfois s est imposé justement
délirer autour d'un dessert que
j'appelais la pêche n'a pas d'âge
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique que le monde allemand
[Musique]
dernière soirée avant la pré rentrée des
enseignants demain matin un retour en
classe particulière entre protocole
sanitaire jugé trop léger par un
collectif de médecins et une composition
de grenades de professeurs par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
l'union européenne de nouveau pointé du
doigt pour sa gestion de la crise
migratoire par plusieurs politiques et
associations humanitaires en cause des
déboires de plusieurs navires le
michel de l'artiste banksy en détresse
ce week end et le site watch quatre qui
attend toujours un port de débarquement
président michel aoun appel a déclaré le
liban état laïc
les poids lourds de la communauté
sunnite du pays du cèdre annonce
s'entendre sur le nom d'un diplomate
mustapha habib comme premier ministre et
ce alors que le hezbollah se dit prêt à
discuter d'un pacte politique
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue sur rt france pour une
nouvelle demi heure d'information j -1
avant la pré rentrée scolaire celle des
enseignants dont certains prévoient de
manifester demain après midi en région
parisienne avec les séances et
l'étudiant pour apaiser les tensions le
ministre de l'éducation propose un
grenelle des professeurs avec la crise
sanitaire ya deux jours de la grande
rentrée jean michel blanc coeur tend la
main au corps enseignant annonce ce
matin dans le journal du dimanche alors
que 12 millions d'élèves sont attendus
sur les bancs d'école dès mardi une
table ronde axée sur les salaires et les
conditions de travail
le chantier de la deuxième partie du
quinquennat c'est la revalorisation du
métier sur le plan financier mais plus
généralement pour améliorer le bien-être
au travail
c'est pourquoi je lance un grenelle des
professeurs d'ici à octobre nous
discuterons de la hausse des
rémunérations pour 2021
grâce aux 400 millions d'euros
supplémentaires obtenus et à partir de
novembre
nous négocierons pour définir une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle
mais ça passe aussi par une
transformation profonde du système
éducatif et gestion des ressources
humaines place des enseignants dans la
société des maîtres heureux ce sont des
élèves heureux
une rentrée dans le protocole sanitaire
est jugé trop léger par un collectif de
médecins qui a signé une tribune ce
week-end dans le parisien il estime que
les mesures dans les écoles ne
protégeront je cite ni les personnels ni
les élèves et leurs familles et médecins
signataires préconisent notamment le
port du masque obligatoire pour les
enfants de plus de six ans écoutez à ce
sujet le directeur du département de
médecine générale de la faculté de lille
mathieu calafiore l'un des signataires
de cette tribune
on sait que les enfants qui sont
symptomatiques les enfants qui ont des
signes un contamine de la même manière
qu'un adulte c'est à dire qu'ils
produisent du virus et ils peuvent le
diffuser de la même manière ce qu'on ne
sait pas à l'heure actuelle ce sont les
enfants asymptomatique et enfants qui
n'ont pas de chef qui n'ont pas tous et
cetera mais qui serait porteur du virus
e on ne sait pas trop comment ils
diffusent le virus ça c'est vraiment la
grande inconnue pour l'instant
et donc on sait que certains enfants
sont de la même manière que les adultes
des vecteurs de contamination du virus
donc si on peut essayer d'éviter de
faire d'eux une source de propagation de
cette de ce vieil de scor en à virus ça
fait quand même quelque chose de sympa
pour eux parce que il faut pas oublier
que les enfants savent qu'ils peuvent
être potentiellement contagieux ils le
savent ils le disent à partir de 6 ans
ils ont peur de contaminer leurs proches
eh bien pourquoi ne pas leur dire si tu
as peur de ça mais ton masque et puis tu
pourras protéger tes parents tes grands
parents tes amis et les personnes plus
fragiles autour de toi pour rassurer
élèves parents et enseignants en plein
rebond épidémie du courant navires us
cabrials attal assure que tout est mis
en place pour la rentrée
le porte parole du gouvernement annonce
la mise en place de centres de dépistage
gratuit à paris
on a franchi la barre historique des 900
mille tests réalisés en une semaine
ll ya des files d'attentes importante
dans les grandes villes en cette rentrée
on va continuer à développer les
capacités de test dès ce lundi
on va voir des barnums de tests devant
les mairies pour se faire tester sans
ordonnance les parisiens pourront se
rendre dans ces centres de dépistage
temporaire devant l'hôtel de ville ainsi
que les mairies du 15e et du 19e
arrondissement de la capitale
puis ça va tourner dans tous les
arrondissements dans ce contexte de
rebond épidémique
le personnel des ehpad alerte le
gouvernement pour l'association des
directeurs au service des personnes
âgées à la dpa je cite la réaction de
l'état doit être rapide car il faut dans
l'urgence renforcer les équipes des
personnels complémentaires et des
emplois aider le personnel des maisons
de retraite réclament un meilleur suivi
psychologique des seniors on écoute
didier sapy le directeur de la
fédération nationale avenir et qualité
de vie des personnes âgées alors
l'urgence elle est humaine
elle est en moyens humains pour soutenir
les équipes des établissements et des
services à domicile
qui aujourd'hui sont fatigués en grande
difficulté face à face au roc bon
potentiel de l'épidémie donc la première
priorité allait effectivement humaine il
nous faut trouver des ressources
humaines les remplacements sont de plus
en plus difficile
il ya des territoires qui sont influents
sinistrés en la matière les personnels
s'inquiète terriblement sont angoissés
même par une communication parfois très
angoissante
autour d'eux autour des établissements
et tout ça est extrêmement fatigant
usant pour les équipes y en a qui ont
besoin d'être renforcées les
remplacements je me disais sont
difficiles ont besoin de soutien
psychologique et mon besoin de plus de
ressources humaines ou dans les
établissements nombreuses réactions
lendemain des manifestations anti masque
en europe 38 mille militants à berlin un
millier de personnes à londres
mobilisation également en suisse et en
france à paris où 200 à 300 personnes
ont manifesté
la préfecture de police de la capitale
annonce 123 verbalisation pour non port
du masque le président allemand un cycle
maire de la capitale britannique sont
montés au créneau sur les réseaux
sociaux tout à l'heure et en france
consensus au sein de la classe politique
objectif faire preuve de civisme
si quelqu'un est énervé par les mesure
où les remet en question il peut le
faire même en public et lors de
manifestations ma compréhension s'arrête
quand des manifestants se mêle à ennemis
de la démocratie et des agitateurs
politiques
mon masque vous protège votre masque me
protège il faut vaincre le coc u19 et
non pas apprendre à vivre avec
il faut créer les conditions pour
protéger c'est ce que nous avons fait à
nice entre le port du masque obligatoire
et des mesures strictes ce n'est pas
très agréable mais c'est indispensable
portons nos masques soyons prudents
protégeons nous les uns les autres pour
surmonter la coved 19 l'union de nos
forces
au delà de nos clivages partisans et
nécessaire nous mettons la santé des
marseillais et des marseillais est au
coeur de nos actions avec les bons
gestes je suis une barrière au virus
le gouvernement porte une responsabilité
terrible dans le doute de la population
après nous avoir dit que ça ne servait à
rien de porter le masque il est
maintenant obligatoire mais il faut que
les masques soit gratuit maintenant
autres manifestations en france cet
après midi à paris un rassemblement de
plusieurs dizaines de personnes sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville de la
capitale contre les violences en
biélorussie et ce alors qu'un nouveau
rassemblement a eu lieu aujourd'hui à
minsk pour dénoncer la réélection du
président alexandre loukachenko
réactions à paris au micro de piotr de
chasseurs t je suis particulièrement
troublés par le sort que subit le peuple
biélorusse qui est un peuple extrêmement
sympathique qui est au coeur de l'europe
il a adopté les les valeurs
démocratiques et qui est foulée aux
pieds par un dictateur les élections
surtout parce qu'on est des plus de 100
personnes villes russes qui habitent en
france qui n'ont pas pu voter le jour de
l'élection
on n'était pas tout simplement admis à
l'ambassade et on a passé
voilà toute la journée on n'est pas
certain que que nous va vous être prises
en compte
j'espère 100% que ça change et les bébés
de l'ue c'est lé peuple est libre
si berlin convoque l'ambassadeur
biélorusse en allemagne paris condamne
les mesures répressives à l'encontre de
la presse on cause
plusieurs journalistes étrangers arrêtés
et privé d'accréditation des violences
ont émaillé la marche
le tout à l'heure rixe entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
dans le même temps le président russe
vladimir poutine et son homologue
alexandre loukachenko se sont entretenus
par téléphone
minsk et moscou qui réaffirment leur
volonté de continuer à renforcer
l'alliance entre les deux pays et de
développer une coopération mutuellement
avantageuse dans tous les domaines fin
de la visite en france du ministre
chinois des affaires étrangères après
avoir rencontré emmanuel macron vendredi
wang li s'est entretenu hier avec son
homologue jean yves le drian les deux
hommes qui insiste sur le développement
du multilatéralisme dans le monde
le chef de la diplomatie s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui à paris devant l'institut
français des relations internationales
il a est revenu notamment sur la
situation des ouigours et de hong kong
nous nous tenons fermement aux côtés de
la france sont tous points du monde pour
revenir sur la situation dans le cygne
change les droits en termes d'éducation
le programme de formation interne flash
câble bien que leur esprit était empiété
par le terrorisme et l'extrémisme
parce que c'est une école où ils ont
amené des compétences et des lois pour
houston en ce qui concerne depuis kong
tous les pays et régions y compris la
france dispose de lois sur la sécurité
enfin vous aimez le la relève du pouvoir
du gouvernement central j'ai tout bien
lâché tu sais où nous ne pouvions
certainement pas rester les bras croisés
et laisser le chaos continue et donc
promulguer une loi de maintien de la
sécurité nationale qui convient
spécifiquement à la situation
hong kong encore d'autres futurs et en
marge de cette visite une manifestation
en soutien ouigours et aux tibétains a
eu lieu ce matin à paris une
cinquantaine de personnes rassemblées
dans le quartier de montparnasse parmi
les slogans solidarité avec le peuple
ouïghour protestation qui dénonce la
venue du ministre chinois des affaires
étrangères à paris mais aussi l'attitude
de la france à l'égard de pékin
nous espérons vraiment que le président
français emmanuel macron affirmera haut
et fort
les valeurs de la france et expliquera
qu'il y a par exemple les génocides des
ouigours maintenant ça a été validée
malheureusement il ya même des
représentants juifs qui parle d'un
génocide donc c'est quand même très très
fort les camps de concentration on en
parle depuis des années nous les
associations
ça fait quatre cinq ans qu'on en parle
on nous disait vous n'avez pas de preuve
alors maintenant nous avons des preuves
grâce à la pandémie dont nous espérons
maintenant que le gouvernement français
va faire passer les droits de l'homme
avant les contrats
la question migratoire de nouveau
d'actualité en europe en cause les
déboires ce week-end du navire
humanitaire affrété par l'artiste
britannique banksy louise michel et les
difficultés du site web 4 toujours à la
recherche d'un port de débarquement
retour sur les faits du week end avec
elle à medjahed le bateau de secours aux
migrants louise michel a été évacué dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche
49 personnes jugées vulnérables ont été
transférés en priorité par les
gardes-côtes italiens
les autres rescapés ont été déplacées à
bord du navire humanitaire al mansi
watch quatre au total ils étaient deux
cents dix-neuf naufragés à être secouru
par le louise michel navires
humanitaires financés par l'artiste
banksy sa première opération de
sauvetage s'était déroulée ce jeudi
une volontaire raconte le premier des
deux sauvetages il était assez difficile
de les trouver car le temps était
mauvais le vent augmentait les vagues
étaient très fortes et il nous a fallu
un certain temps pour y arriver il s'est
avéré que c'était un bateau en
caoutchouc très surpeuplé environ 90
personnes sur le bateau qui avait déjà
passé quelques jours en mer qui était
donc épuisé
déshydraté certaines d'entre elles
avaient le mal de mer à cause des
conditions météorologiques et était en
hypothermie
le bateau se trouvait ce samedi dans une
zone de recherches et de secours de
malte le pays qui a contacté des garde
côtes italiens en raison de la
détérioration des conditions
météorologiques
louise michel avait lui aussi lancé
plusieurs appels de détresse pointant du
doigt l'inaction de l'union européenne
voici les survivants dont vous vous
détournez l'union européenne après avoir
échappé à une horreur et une inhumanité
indicible ils ont besoin d'un lieu sûr
vous devez agir maintenant un décès est
à déplorer sur le bateau cette année
plus de 300 migrants auraient trouvé la
mort en méditerranée
un chiffre qui pourrait être beaucoup
plus élevé selon l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations
le bureau de médecins sans frontières au
pays-bas dénonce de son côté la
situation intenable
à vire humanitaire en méditerranée un
autre navire a accosté sur l'île de
lampedusa la nuit dernière avec ce
bateau près de 370 migrants ont gagné le
sud de l'italie une navire a été escorté
par les gardes-côtes italiens ces
derniers ont effectué un contrôle de
température sur tous les migrants
présents à bord avant de les emmener
dans un centre d'accueil ou à 1500
exilés sont déjà logé une situation sans
précédent selon le maire de lampedusa
qui appellent à une grève générale pour
faire réagir les autorités nationales
l'eurodéputé rn gilbert collard dénonce
lui d opération communication politique
de la part des ong humanitaires
ceux qui ne sont pas des réfugiés
politiques repartent
je dirais même que systématiquement
comme eux les lélés les migrants entre
guillemets qui sont à bord de ses
bateaux n'ont aucun titre préexistant à
accoster
on devrait les accompagner vers les eaux
les plus proches se dit en application
du droit international et leur
destination légal mais on cède devant
chantage il ya bien longtemps que
l'europe aurait dû faire la police de la
police maritime et la chasse à ces
bateaux et les saisir vers la haye
imaginez que l'an procèdent à la saisie
et à la vente textes légaux à l'appui de
tous ces bateaux qui à mettre en fraude
quand même le rappeler des migrants qui
n'ont aucun titre juridique jeu c'est
exact plus beaucoup d'importance dans
une haie périodes où c'est l'atmosphère
qui fait la loi et non pas la loi qui
fait le texte
mais si on saisit c'est systématiquement
les bateaux croyez moi il y en aurait 2
moisan 1
ils maurice avec la manifestation hier
d'une dizaine de milliers de personnes à
port louis une protestation contre la
gestion gouvernementale de la marée
noire qui a ravagé la côte sud est du
pays jordi de mourir c'est une foule
comme l'île maurice n'en avait pas vu
depuis près de 40 ans selon les
estimations des organisateurs et de la
presse locale entre 50000 et 75000
personnes ont investi la capitale
mauricienne
le cortège a dénoncé la gestion par le
gouvernement de la marée noire qui a
ravagé la côte sud est de l'île au début
du mois fait cette année pour se baigner
à le mouvement on pourrait te donnais
mon énergie positive à tout ce mouvement
des mauriciens qui pour une fois sont
solidaires dans une action parce qu'il
n'ya pas souvent des gens qui descendent
dans les rues à maurice donc tous que
c'est important d'être là et de soutenir
cette cause là et puis
c'est pour dire noir tout ce qu'on subit
depuis pas mal de temps c'est une
hypothèse qu'on pense
nouvelles demandes
qui a déteint compétents
pendant ces dernières années et
c'est vraiment désolant lui voit à quel
point
tombé aussi bas et on a plus pour notre
avenir et tous nos enfants
torstar c'est fini
s'émouvait m'ont bien arrêtée de
m'utiliser
générac
système en géorgie leur part plus il est
jeune carrière
tiens toi aussi pour les deux frères et
que le gouvernement ne veut pas accepter
le sens pilar ne veut pas accepter que
la grille en fer pour ces catastrophes
le vraquier japonais wasquehal chiot
s'est échoué le 25 juillet dernier sur
un récif à point destiny le navire a
laissé échapper au moins mille tonnes de
fioul qui ont souillé la côte
trois semaines après les paf s'est brisé
en deux après une course contre la
montre pour pomper le carburant qu'elle
contenait de nombreux mauriciens estime
que le gouvernement a trop tardé à
prendre la mesure de la catastrophe et à
organiser le pompage du fioul
le premier ministre au pouvoir depuis
2000 17 a jugé n'avoir commis aucune
erreur et a refusé de présenter des
excuses
je dois dire que le fast intercepteurs
bahout ne pouvait pas être déployé en
raison des houles et d'une mer agitée
cela d'autant plus que les services
météorologiques de maurice avait publié
un bulletin météorologique en date du
samedi 25 juillet 2020 pour un
avertissement de forte houle
parmi les six hélicoptères seul druva
des capacités de vols de nuit mais n'a
pas pu être déployé vu qu'il était en
maintenance jusqu'au 7 août 2020 la
colère des mauriciens a été exacerbée
par la découverte cette semaine d'au
moins 34 dauphin retrouvé mort à
quelques kilomètres du lieu du naufrage
la population de cet archipel de l'océan
indien qui compte 1,3 million
d'habitants a fait le lien avec la
catastrophe écologique
mais selon les premières conclusions
communiquées par le gouvernement les
autopsies n'ont montré aucune trace
d'hydrocarbure dans les organismes des
dauphins d'autres analyses
bactériologiques et toxicologiques
seront toutefois nécessaires pour
exclure définitivement tout lien direct
avec la marée noire
paris favorable à une transition rapide
au mali avant que la situation ne
profite aux terroristes sémantique ce
matin de la ministre française désarmé
florence parly alors
la crise politique persiste depuis une
douzaine de jours après la démission
forcée du président lee bakar ibrahim
boubacar kéïta pas d'accord de fond sur
la transition mais des progrès sont
constatés après la rencontre entre
militaires et membres de l'opposition du
m5 hier soir médias ce qui est fille
avec les musiques au viage après un
rendez vous manqué la rencontre a
finalement eu lieu ce samedi dans la
soirée à l'issue des discussions
si aucun compromis n'a été trouvé entre
les militaires putschistes et le m5 les
tensions semblent en tout cas à plaisait
l'enjeu la transition politique malienne
une transition que le m5 souhaite
organiser conjointement avec les
militaires ne voudrait que le malentendu
a été dissipée le plus important c'est
avancer et nous allons avancer pour
l'intérêt du peuple malien en essayant
d'avoir des concertations des échanges
est aussi
de voir que l'armée c'est l'armée du
peuple pour le peuple par le peuple
cette semaine après avoir obtenu la
libération de l'ancien président malien
la cédéao communauté économique des
états d'afrique de l'ouest a elle aussi
maintenu la pression
les pays voisins ont donné un délai d'un
an aux militaires pour organiser des
élections objectif ramener la société
civile à la tête du pays en échange
l'organisation promet une levée
progressive des sanctions contre le mali
les sanctions seront levés
progressivement en fonction de la mise
en oeuvre de la transition
ces mesures contribueront certainement à
guérir le mali des démons du putschisme
pour un pays le putschiste met une grave
maladie pour en guérir une seule
ordonnance les sanctions aucune
structure militaire ne doit être au
dessus du président de transition
alors que la transition peine à démarrer
la junte militaire met en avant le
colonel assis meego ita qu'elle
considère comme le chef de l'état pour
assurer la continuité de l'état il faut
qu'il y ait un chef d'état cet acte
permet de prendre le président du
conseil national comme le chef d'état ce
qui lui permet d'assurer la continuité
de l'état et préparer la transition
pour l'heure les pays voisins
maintiennent la fermeture des frontières
ainsi que l'embargo sur les échanges
financiers et commerciaux
plusieurs dirigeants redoutent que la
situation au mali ne déstabilise
davantage une région en proie aux
troubles notamment au terrorisme
nouvelle marche contre les violences
policières ce soir à cannes au chat une
semaine après laffaire jack up blake un
afro américain atteint de cette balle
dans le dos alors que des policiers
tentaient de l'interpeller
l'homme de 29 ans et désormais paralysé
des deux jambes hier soir justement un
nouveau rassemblement a eu lieu le père
de jane comme blake qui s'est exprimé à
cette occasion et donald trump dolly se
rendre mardi dans cette ville symbole du
wisconsin on a tiré sept balles dans le
dos de mon fils je suis ici avec mes
soeurs et mes frères bon sens oui je
suis en colère mais vous comprenez quand
vous mettez en colère vous perdez le
contrôle de votre propre nature ma
nature c'est de protéger mon fils de me
tenir debout pour mon fils quand il ne
peut pas le faire est de demander aux
policiers de cette ville ce qui leur a
donné le droit de tenter de tuer mon
fils qu'est ce qui leur a donné le droit
de penser que mon fils était un animal
[Musique]
et puis du côté de portland une personne
a perdu la vie la nuit dernière dans des
circonstances encore très floues
cette ville de la côte ouest américaine
est le théâtre d'affrontements depuis
plusieurs semaines entre manifestants
anti raciste et partisan de donald trump
illustration avec cette violente bagarre
de rue les états unis plus que jamais
divisée depuis la mort de l'afro
américain joe hart floyd lors d'une
arrestation policière controversée à
minneapolis le 25 mai dernier
la turquie a repris hier ses exercices
militaires en mer méditerranée orientale
les manoeuvres doivent durer deux
semaines elle symbolise les tensions
grandissantes entre ankara et athènes
toujours au sujet des ressources
d'hydrocarbures ce matin à florence
parly s'est exprimé la ministre des
armées des plans un comportement je cite
escale à thouars de la turquie la
turquie conteste l'existence de zones
économiques exclusives met en cause la
souveraineté de deux états membres de
l'union européenne la grèce et chypre et
mais potentiellement en danger un droit
fondamental qu'est la liberté de
navigation
il y ait un droit de navigation dans les
eaux de la méditerranée
il n'y a pas de droits d'accaparement de
ressources énergétiques et gazière
surtout lorsque celles ci ont été
reconnus conformément aux traités
internationaux
michel aoun appel a déclaré le liban
état laïc
le président libanais qui s'est exprimé
ce soir à l'occasion des 100 ans du pays
du cèdre
les leaders de la communauté sunnite
annoncent-elles s'entendre sur le nom du
diplomate mustapha a dit comme nouveau
premier ministre
et dans le même temps le hezbollah se
dit prêt à discuter d'un pacte politique
comme en ce qui concerne le gouvernement
nous supposons espérons dans la volonté
de dieu que demain quand les
consultations parlementaires débuteront
les différents blocs du parlement
libanais seront en mesure de nommer un
candidat qui recevra l'approbation
nécessaire au niveau constitutionnel
pour former un nouveau gouvernement
nous avons besoin d'un gouvernement
capable d'améliorer la situation
économique financière la vie quotidienne
et aussi de conduire des reconstructions
et des réformes face à la situation
complexe que connaît le liban la finul
la mission de paix dans le pays a été
reconduite pour un an par l'onu la
résolution a été votée à l'unanimité par
le conseil de sécurité
[Musique]
on écoute l'analyse 2 khattar abou diab
politologue spécialiste du moyen-orient
comme mission a été effectuée
elle soutient la population civile au
sud liban
el assir aussi l'aspect la population
civile israélien au nord d'israël
donc elles n'arrivent pas bien sûr
lorsqu'il ya une tension énorme où des
accrochages comme c'était le cas entre
palestiniens et israéliens avant 1982
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui entre les
résultats et sahel la fine il ne
parvient pas à assumer son rôle et là
c'est les blacks presse c'est à dire là
il faut vraiment voir comment donner à
cette mission un contenu et de la
substance pour empêcher il ne prendre
déflagration au sud liban
emmanuel macron selon lui demain au
liban après près d'un mois après la
double explosion
du port de beyrouth c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de votre acte de
votre fidélité on se retrouve d'ici une
demi-heure pour un nouveau point complet
sur information à ce t shirt et france
[Musique]
je peux vite a été le révélateur des
monstres aux pieds d'argile que nous
sommes la france et je l'aidais elle
veut devenir veut partout mais on n'a
pas les moyens
ma critique de ce que nous continuerons
à nier l'évidence c'est à dire nous
continuer à mentir sur la réalité de
notre pouvoir qui est devenu comme
plâtre dont est ce que cette france là
vous fait moins peur que celle que vous
avez décrite ses parts à nos membres de
la france objet peur c'est 2 du ca qui
pourrait être des prêts d'être réservé à
notre beau pays
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour en remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression emploi l'étude
démontre la nocivité de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine au nom de la peur de la mort
notre ministre a interdit immédiatement
son utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société
active dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique
les technocrates et activiste et de
nombreux journalistes ne s'intéressent
qu'à la partie qui va dans leur sens et
censure ou dévalorise le reste fonds
décide de ce que le peuple doit penser
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débrief du doc
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder un sujet
peu commun mais préoccupant les débris
spatiaux
c'est l'objet de notre documentaire no
'future' fléaux de notre temps les
déchets de l'espace et pour nous
éclairer sur ce sujet je reçois
aujourd'hui pierrot maliki et expert en
sécurité des vols spatiaux au centre
national d'études spatiales le cnes
bonjour pierre au mali merci d'être avec
nous alors vous êtes expert en débris
spatiaux alors tout d'abord qu'avez vous
pensé de notre documentaire est ce
qu'ils reflètent vos préoccupations
aujourd'hui oui donc j'ai effectivement
documentaire tout à fait intéressant je
pense un petit peu à la alarmiste
surtout au début mais bon il faut il
faut savoir attirer l'intérêt du
spectateur
la problématique des débris
effectivement un problème qui
aujourd'hui est d'actualité
nous sommes en plus en pleine expansion
acial avec des nouveaux arrivants comme
nos collègues américains spécifique ce
qui envoie plein de nouveaux satellites
pour faire des constatations internet et
donc il ya de plus en plus d'objets dans
l'espace et donc puis il ya d'objets et
puis à des risques de collision donc le
reportage donne des éléments tout à fait
tout à fait intéressant de réflexion et
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on va expliquer
certains pas que c'était reparti pour
pouvoir peut-être les rendre plus
compréhensible est moins alarmiste mais
tout autre mais tout aussi intéressante
savait alors en effet on apprend dans ce
documentaire que des millions voire des
centaines de millions de fragments qui
sont imposants ou minuscules tourne au
dessus de nos têtes à très grande
vitesse ils proviennent des pav de
satellite ou de vaisseau alors
dites-nous pierre au mali comment sont
ils arrivés ici dès le premier lancement
de satellite par les russes